this isn't a movie trailer it's part of
a recruitment Drive aimed at encouraging
more young people to join the Chinese
Army
[Music]
we don't live in a peaceful time the
voiceover says we just live in a
peaceful country this month revisions on
Military recruitment came into effect
creating a legal framework for the
conscription of veterans during wartime
back to their original units or a
similar role and prioritizing the
enlistment of University students and
graduates from Science and Technology
disciplines
and that is clearly looking to the
Future the military will be organized in
a way that is very technology driven so
that's very clear so they want to start
a process and to have the legal
framework in place just in case
experts say the government is trying to
fill military gaps
president XI Japan I think as well as
his predecessors for a number of years
outline deficiencies within the pla
citing that it is not fit for purpose
and has not been for quite some time and
of course as stated by the Chinese
government this is part and parcel of
what it means to be a great power
China already has the largest armed
forces in the world with more than 3
million military personnel including
military police around 30 percent of
them are conscripts serving a mandatory
two years since president Xi Jinping
came to power the Army also known as the
pla has undergone rapid modernization
still experts say some challenges Remain
the lack of comrade experience is a
challenge for the plate however I think
there are bigger challenges for the pla
at the moment for them to turn into the
type of military that they seek to
become with this latest round of
modernization and that requires not just
structural changes but also changes in
thinking China faces several
geopolitical flash points in the South
China Sea along its border with India
and over Taiwan there have been several
changes in recent years aimed at
boosting recruitment including improving
conditions for personnel and creating
more avenues for career progression
based on performance
experts say these changes reflect
beijing's desire to professionalize its
forces and encourage qualified young
people to see the military as an
attractive career option while also
preparing for the prospect that one day
they may be called upon to fight whether
they like it or not Jessica Washington
altazira Beijing